today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
my savvy fans secure their internet
join them at expressvpn.com yang
[Music]
and i appreciated the fact that you know
recently on social media you started
engaging politically you were like look
this stuff's kind of important
let's like actually talk things out and
like you know be reasonable human beings
which you know i completely agree with
yes but it's difficult to get like
even people who agree with you if you're
just like here's this point
and even people would agree like yeah
cause those cry baby lives blew it and
said no no listen man
if you're here we're all gonna engage in
some talking and uh
i want both there should be more than
two signs but that's a whole other
conversation but i
wanted to be human beings engaging
and not just being so mad that they want
to go out in the streets or
wish death on somebody talking about
politics
um i don't disagree that we need a
different
level of dynamism in our political
system uh that right now the duopoly is
not
great for anyone
[Music]
and it is now my pleasure to welcome to
yang speaks
two-time former wwe champion
headlining stand-up comedian actor
in films tv you might know him as dolph
ziggler
but we know him as nick nemeth nick
welcome to yang speaks
what a great day this is for us this is
big
yeah i am so pumped to connect with you
because i i there's so much i want to
like ask you uh and unpack
uh so the the first thing is i was
looking at your background you should
know so i'm a fan
of wrestling so i remember when you
debuted
i remember your progression i remember
when you were like the unsung
high level performer that they
eventually gave a chance
um and like now i but even i did not
know
just how deep your athletic background
went where you were a high level
high school and college wrestler you
were high school teammates with some
animals freaking like gray maynard like
the ufc contender was on your high
school wrestling team and i just thought
to myself holy crap
like like nick that's pretty wild i a
real quick story about that i
i grew up in cleveland uh 15 minutes
away from saint edward high school which
happened to be
a wrestling powerhouse like not state
champions
national champions like amazing amazing
guy i was
okay i was very average-y okay
but gray maynard was one weight class
above me uh
andy robot was three weight classes but
he's a u.s olympian
like there are some studs that came out
of there and went on to college and i
think i got a little bit better in
college but
i have had some crazy uh just teammates
just go on to just be
i oh it's a podcast i get to wear ass
kickers like so it's pretty it's pretty
wild you know
yeah podcast rules are you can say
whatever the [ __ ] you
that's like it's not it's not on
usa or uh you know whatever network that
you're going to be on
uh so uh so the the
legend is that you realize you wanted to
be a professional wrestler
quite young uh so did you actually
become a high school wrestler in part
because you even had this ambition in
your head
not even in part 100 like the plan was
uh this is
i tell this story and stand up all the
time i was five years old
uh cleveland didn't even have an arena
so we had to drive out to rich
the richfield coliseum that's where the
cavs played when i was a kid and we sat
in the
farthest away seats and there was no big
titan trons no big shows it was just
entrances and guys came out and uh after
the show
we were so far away i told my dad i go i
want to be a wrestler i want to do this
and he goes okay but you got to start
wrestling in a little bit different
style so
at five years old he signed me up for
just one
one or two days a week wrestling with my
friends uh at my grade school
and i no joke i walked in the door and
go where's the ring where's the chairs
where's everything this is different
and i go okay so i i did it and the
whole goal
through grade school high school college
even was like
i go if i can break some records in
college and you can google my name as
like this all-time winning wrestler
they'll have to give me a try out right
because you know and uh
and luckily that's that's what it was uh
just because having a background where
you can google my name
and i was like i just as i graduated i
broke the record for most wins at my
school which is
one of the goals i had i mean that
that's an incredible
ambition when you're uh you know five
years old
and thereafter i went to wwe house shows
uh when i was young too and you're right
there's no titan tron it's just dudes
come out
and guys come out and that's it and it's
uh it was still fun you know
what's the so i'm assuming you don't
like paint your face
or wear a title but did you did you like
have a special shirt ready to go like
i'm going to wear my undertaker's shirt
you know it's a big show or j like
what's the deal
i was a macho man guy but i didn't have
like macho man paraphernalia
and i don't think he performed though
the birds weren't everywhere like they
are today
like it was hard to come by try to wait
six to eight weeks in the mail or
something like you know
it was a different time yeah when you go
you go to the house show too
when i went like it was confusing
initially because there's no commentary
in your ear either you're just there and
just like watching these
these guys go at it
but it's still tremendous i mean it was
it was formative i remember i waited
uh you know in line to to meet various
wrestlers
andre the giant performed at the show i
was at and the guy was just
so enormous larger than life it was like
i was pretty young so i was like holy
[ __ ] if i like tucked into a ball this
guy could
like you know eat me like stuff in his
mouth or you know
guys in wrestling now but none of them
were like that's
like that's and as you're a kid you go
oh this
is like a person from a movie not real
life like that's
i i can't believe that i was a small kid
that freaked me well
so that that's actually a question
because when i was a kid you know i had
fanciful thoughts like oh i'm going to
uh be a pro wrestler and like i had some
moniker but
you know not nowhere near as uh
as action-oriented as as your ambition
so did your family have an athletic
background like uh how
realistic was this when you were
hatching this plan back in
uh you know people will go like oh i
told my parents i was going to hollywood
to become a star and they're like yeah
right or something but
i was a little bit of a showman or you
know
annoying i guess always on as a child
even so
when i was like hey this is what i want
to do no one was like yeah right they're
like oh yeah that makes sense
and i was like okay we made a deal i
made a deal with my parents i said
this doesn't work out for a lot of
people uh i will graduate college first
to have something to fall back on
back when that was a big deal graduating
college you know when it made sense
yeah i know i remember
[Music]
and i sorry i did that and uh i go once
i graduate then i'm gonna
i'm gonna go to law school during the
day and wrestling school at night and
it's a whole i had it all planned out
and um and uh luckily um
i moved to arizona to live in my uh um
and uncle's
guest bedroom to have residency for a
year
and then it would turn out that law
school would be way cheaper than it
would normally be
had it all worked out yeah had it all
worked out i never would have been able
to do all the hours and do wrestling
school and all that stuff but while i
was waiting
to go to school at asu i got my tryout
with wwe
so it all worked out somehow
yeah the the the fact that you had law
school
uh you know as your back burner or your
your fallback i gotta say man you dodged
a bullet
because like you as like
[Laughter]
you now is like the former champ
like you know 10 time intercontinental
champ or whatever whatever you are like
headliner versus like another [ __ ]
miserable lawyer i mean that's like a
very very
large gap so i would have been so
miserable
to have like we used to travel so much
before covet but i
used to have little bags of eyes i can't
imagine being a miserable lawyer
keeps his shirt on all day long can't
like vent out the frustration
and constantly go or waiting to hoping
to be
part of work somewhere like junior
parker 20 years later oh
god i yeah i think i dodged a bullet i
think yeah you definitely did and the
world's better off for it
[Laughter]
we didn't need uh nick nemeth attorney
at law that
that's that's for sure uh so
so you get this wwe tryout you go
through this entire crazy developmental
ring or you're in like the
um you know in um think it was ovw back
closer to where you grew up uh and i
have to say the wwe
initially saddled you with like the
shittiest gimmicks
i mean just getting to normal or average
after
the past that i've had i feel like is a
win
but it's yeah i came in as as uh
chavo guerrero playing an alter ego's
caddy
to manage him and a cheerleader and i
know
i played every sport there is they used
to tell me uh when i was in ohio valley
restaurant they're like
we really like that you're a clean cut
kid you work hard you did all these
sports you're good at wrestling
we're thinking about bringing you in
maybe with uh kurt angle and i go whoa
know that that's like my hero because he
like caught on so well
there's a reason a smaller guy like me
got a try out and they're like
that's it you're coming up you're gonna
be a golf caddy and i go
what like uh and it's just
that and the cheerleader stuff and then
cut to two years later
and i'm like in the ring with cena we're
fighting
and i'm just no longer a guy but you're
still getting nikki
chance as a cheerleader and it's like
i'm fighting uphill no matter what
already but i feel like all those things
made me work so much harder to be better
at my job so that people would forget
about it
so i guess it helped in the long run
that's a really good attitude about it
man because i they did not do you any
favors
i didn't have that attitude then just so
you know
so so in addition to being literally
like a championship level college
wrestler at kent state like what other
sports did you play
um i until college i played everything
uh football baseball i bowled on the
weekends i love bowling
uh but uh everything kind of at soccer i
played like uh
intramural hockey uh i did everything
that we could offer i just
even now i i'm very active
uh i don't sleep a bunch i love sports i
love doing things
uh i just i played everything how about
you what did you do
this could be just you know it's gonna
be a half interview of you also so this
is interesting i know
i mean i no i sure i mean i'm happy to
share my my
vaunted athletic background
for me i was like the uh i was the nerdy
asian kid who skipped a grade so i was
always like smaller and scrawnier
i uh name it except for skipping
obviously
so i i did wrestle uh terribly
for like a year uh like in eighth or
ninth grade
and like i i think my record was
literally something like one in eight
i was like dude
um yeah i think i did get a win in there
yeah
like i mean it was like buried in so
many losses that
there's like this is not the sport for
you um and then
uh you know i played high school tennis
and uh
like uh like intramural basketball so
it's pretty low-level [ __ ]
i just got i just tried it like two
years ago with a fellow wrestler cesaro
who is
the strongest uh smartest guy
and we played we were in uh the middle
east
and we played for a half an hour and we
were
drenched and he was taking it easy on me
and i know one of us is going to have to
say we have to stop
at some point but we both refused to and
then luckily he had some mercy on me
he's like hey we'll play one more point
but it was like
120 degrees running back and forth and
he was taking it easy
and i go i don't know how people play
this game for an hour like no way
in real life like that's intense
well for me it actually kicked in a
little bit older uh you know i started
doing martial arts in my teens
and uh college years and then competed a
bit in that
um also lost more than i won
so i was like that like the guy who like
other people like pad their records
against
uh that was you were building character
so yeah that was my equivalent of
getting
of having some adversity to to fight
through um
so so uh so you become
this uh this star almost against all
odds in my opinion
uh and i have to say as a fan like your
talent level really did
shine through uh and someone gave you
the highest compliment
i can think of which is they called you
the second coming of kurt hennig
uh and like mr perfect was one of one of
you know the
the people that um i admired a ton
uh growing up and it's really a pretty
good description man because you're just
so athletic
you tell such good stories in the ring
you can make anyone look good
uh it's and so even though they they
made it hard for you i feel like this
was like a
an example of um talent rising to the
top
uh i i think i guess so because so i
didn't know how this works i didn't have
uh i wasn't a legacy i didn't have
someone in the business i
showed up and just didn't know except
that i loved didn't want to do it and
i thought after i was a caddy and they
sent me back i thought i was fired and
it was over and i have another chance
and then i became a cheerleader and then
they sent us back and i go okay this
time i'm fired nobody gets three chances
i go but if i do get a third chance i
want them to have no excuse but to be
begging me to be on their show so i just
and i've been working hard
above and beyond to catch up to
everybody cause i didn't work the
independence i was just a fan so i was
every day i was trying to go i was
trying to get
three years of training into six months
and i go i want to give them every
excuse that they're begging
for me to be in this ring and i i did i
watched i was big mr perfect guy because
he was also
a wrestler and did the old minnesota
like awa
like real wrestling that transpired into
this
and also he knew to put on a big show
and i was like
uh at the time our business when i was
brand new into 2004-2005
we're doing the we were still going
wrestling big
and you know the way i was taught and
trained to like have
everybody in all four corners of the
arena see what you're doing
and then a year into my training which i
was going insane for they're like
now it's reality based don't do any of
that [ __ ] you've been doing
that you've been burning into my brain i
was like oh god so then
i always had the i can shoot as we call
and like
make some things real but also i can
make things bigger and have a show of it
so that combination
much like mr perfect was uh i mean what
great company to be compared to so
well you earned it man you earned it the
hard way
[Music]
this is a really tough time for small
businesses everywhere
and as someone who's run a small
business zach's run a business too
uh one of the toughest things is trying
to find people
quickly promptly reliably to help
do whatever you need to get done and
indeed.com is the number one job site in
the world
a lot of these markets uh function in a
way that
eventually one of the markets gets the
most critical mass
and in this space it's indeed.com
where it's at this point the go-to
destination for both
employers and folks who are looking for
a job
you know we used it on the campaign
indeed.com
is the go-to place yeah i've used it a
lot
personally um frankly
it's just simple and you only pay what
you need right you you can pause anytime
or
uh and restart any time so right now
indeed is offering our yang speaks
listeners
a free 75 credit to boost your job posts
which means you get the quality
candidates that see it fast
so try it indeed with a free 75 credit
at indeed.com
yang this is the best offer available
anywhere
for this type of service so go right now
to indeed.com
yang terms and conditions apply offer
valid through september 30th
[Music]
like you seem like the picture of health
uh
you know i mean
but i i feel like you all put your
bodies through so much particularly with
the road schedule i mean
now with kovid uh your schedule i'd
imagine is
uh completely different in that it's
once a week you go into the thunder dome
crazy yeah it's uh
oh please please no but before but in
normal times it was more like
uh several house shows a week some
televised some not
on the road what four days a week i'd
imagine
uh and as someone who's uh traveled a
lot it's like not great on your body
uh to constantly be in a car
playing a car getting choked slammed
four nights a week like yeah all that
adds up and uh
no i've had the craziest i i loved it we
had the craziest
non-stop schedule every year we were
adding shows and
i sometimes before we did drafts and
brands i was sometimes doing friday live
event for
for the raw brand and then saturday
sunday monday we do raw
tuesday we would do smackdown and then
i'd come home on wednesday and friday i
was back out or sometimes thursday at a
red eye
that was kind of west coast so i did
that non-stop
travel for eight years in a row
and then now it's one day a week i feel
like i'm on vacation and i don't even
work there anymore it's crazy i'm at
my i'm at my house and like oh okay i
get what this looks like
i know which side my gas tank is on my
car like all these crazy things that uh
but the travel sitting in a car sitting
on a plane falling down a bunch
it takes a toll on you but i i've been
very lucky
uh except for one or two concussions
uh no surgeries no crazy
uh injuries um i work out hard i'm
very active i uh on most of our off days
at home i'm doing two workouts a day
just to
kill the hours and let them go by so i'm
i think i'm in like better shape now
than i was a few years ago
um and also i can work smart and hard at
the same time which is a little bit of a
trick
so for you you be on the road so much
and then this conversion i feel like
this must be opening up all new parts of
your
yeah your life or your brain or or
uh or i'm thinking actually also like a
different
set of relationships because like all of
a sudden instead of being on the road
four or five days a week
like you know now it's like hey i'm in
one place i kind of know where i'm gonna
be next tuesday like that's different
it's wild yeah it really is it's totally
different and uh
it's funny because like with kobe with
people being shut down it's a lot of
people
breaking up with their girlfriends or
losing friends or something like that
because
everyone's isolated or have to stay away
or stuck with somebody
and i'm used to doing my own thing which
is weird but like
waking up and not having an alarm for 3
45 a.m
and going oh right i have 20 hours to go
work out and then eat whatever i want
like this is the best
but it's no it's really it's weird
it is the opposite of my schedule for
the last 10 years so it's weird but it's
it's good to mix it up and get a change
like this i'm lucky i'm not one of the
100 million people out of work right now
somehow we are able to
keep going and keep doing shows so like
i'm very lucky but also
i'm bored a little bit well
uh and you you probably saw some of the
stuff that came up in social media and
whatnot
um but i have to ask you about wwe's um
they had a recent stance about working
on twitch and cameo like you
you're actually an independent figure
where you're working as a comedian
which i want to talk a lot about because
i think there's a fascinating nexus
between
wrestling and comedy and politics
honestly like i i genuinely think that
there's like a lot of overlap there
um but and i'm on the record saying that
i think that the wwe treating you all as
independent contractors
uh does not make sense it doesn't jive
with reality
uh given the demanding nature of your
schedules how much control they have
over your
activities someone actually sent me a
wwe contract
and i was like wow is this thing
very very heavy in terms of this thick
oh yeah it's it's it's uh
it's a lot in there if you read it oh
yeah if i were to summarize
it's like hey we have control over just
about anything
you do that like you appear in in any
form of media that exists or could ever
exist
so so like the control is to me is very
high
uh and you know i'm on the record saying
that
like the independent contractor
classification does not make sense given
the degree of control
uh and also the the um
like the the level to which wwe is
benefiting
um now in your case you're like a very
very high level performer you've
succeeded there
uh you know and have like a very very
long track record
um and you don't have to answer this if
you don't want but like do you have any
thoughts
on wwe's classification of performers
yeah and it's it it's a gray area
because uh for 10 years i've gone back
and forth i'm like how does this make
sense but i i see some points here and
there so
and as much as i like to stick it to the
man you know i'm a bad boy like you i
don't wear the tie
always but it's uh there are
some points i that i i'm normally mad at
me that
they make because we i am representing
that company even when i go
do a comedy show or go on fox news to do
something so
if i'm doing something on the outside
i'm still representing them a little bit
you have to think in the back your head
so uh and then long term when it comes
to maybe
me getting uh i'm making this up a
muscle milk deal
or something so if i did that
theoretically it is because of wwe that
someone knows me
possibly but also you could i mean you
see that instagram
shirtless yeah i'm still the real deal
so it's fine but
if if they wanted to come to me with a
deal they go hey
we'll give you a couple hundred bucks
and all the muscle milk you can drink
and it's like it's almost a kramer
coffee uh episode
of seinfeld and you're like oh okay cool
and they're like well
wwe behind the scenes was working on a
five million dollar deal with muscle
milk and i just kind of ruined it
because
i kind of cheapened myself out so
there's a little bit of both sides we
have to understand
you're still working for a brand even
though i
i heard you on chris van glid's show
like where it's like disney can't own a
character that worked in their movie and
is going to do something else but
uh for the most part even though that
paperwork is this thick
um as long as it's not bad mouthing the
company
or that you work for a couple other
things you get more and more leeway and
that paperwork is there i think to
protect them
whether you think it's fair or not which
i understand uh but i
also after a while you ask and sometimes
you get told that it wouldn't be great
for the company to do this but you can
make your own decision
but i've also it took me 12 years of
doing things
and being sent to other countries on a
pr tour
to go they can trust me to go do
something else so i get both sides of
that
but also when it comes to independent
contractors should maybe be able to wear
whatever the hell we want do what we
want and as long as we're there on
monday to do the match you know what i
mean i get that
uh but also uh you have to remember like
you're
you're representing the dnc sometimes
you know what i mean and you can
and you which i'm a fan of yours i'm a
huge fan
because you're transparent about things
you don't just go nancy pelosi told me
to say this so i'm saying it and we got
this in our notes today you go well
actually
here's the good part and here's the bad
part and being able to do that
is not only refreshing but i try and do
the same thing
like well here's a good part here's the
bad part but at the end of the day
if you want to be in the cabinet or if
you want to be president you have to
be a part of their team somewhat which
i'm i'm guessing but i'm assuming that's
the case
so i see both i think there are some
real parallels there
and certainly appreciate the fact that
you've been part of this company that
um you know you developed like an
incredible uh
success incredibly successful uh working
relationship with for
for years and i admire the fact that
you've gotten it to a point where you
are
branching out and doing all these things
that are clearly just born of you
that are like 100 nick um because i'm
sure
because because i'm sure wwe was not
like hey nick
you should do you shouldn't study comedy
for years and years and then go out
there and like open mic it up like
like i doubt that was high on their list
uh
so so tell me about how that developed
because i love it
i love the fact that um that you've
taken up another crowd despite being at
the top of your field
uh and ta and and gone to another field
that is brutally difficult very
unforgiving like there's no
faking it uh you know your your fame
uh and the built up affection that some
of the people in the audience have for
you
lasts for approximately two seconds
[Laughter]
and then it's like hey if you can't make
me laugh then [ __ ] you
so like uh so so how the heck did you
did you start pushing in that direction
uh okay there's a couple pieces there
one it's very similar to wrestling which
is wild
like it's you on the road you travel you
but with wrestling there's someone else
in the ring that you can blame or play
off of or something
but no matter what when you go up on the
stage i am still nervous i'm at like i
don't know
50 or 60 shows i've done something like
that and i go up there and i
have a whiskey beforehand and i go up
there and i'm like nervous and you go
and all of a sudden you just see
all these eyes on you and if it's a
wrestling ring i'm 15 years in
i go i know what i can do we can get
them back with something here
but if i go up there and stutter or miss
a line
and go talk over a word and they're just
staring there like this like
you're really good at wrestling why why
does this suck and you're like oh
god but um i also
so i kind of found like a loophole to
where i get to try out my material
but also wrestling fans get to come and
get their autographs or a picture with
me or something but then they have i do
it beforehand
and then they have to sit through the
show to deal with me with
the material so but i'm also smart
enough i go i know
there's gonna be a bunch of hardcore
wrestling fans at my show so i usually
try and do a formula of like
20 you read the internet you know the
rumors little
little brock lesnar dig about him not
showing up or some kind of joke for the
hardcore fans
and then there's like twenty percent
more of like they know who
the rock john cena and hulk hogan is and
i'm like if the show sucked and i just
tell him i was john cena or whatever and
that's all you need to know
and then i go there's like comedy fans
and people who just came to a show
and it's i about 60 i do just
me going to chipotle me wrestling in con
college me
on tinder or bumble or something and
whatever happens to me so i find a happy
medium
and then uh i'm very lucky that we could
do um because uh for at first i couldn't
do
i'm headlining i can't do an hour no way
now
and uh we found a way for sarah tiana
who is a pro comic and really funny
to where she went up ahead of me she
kills for 20 minutes
i would do 20 or 25 minutes and then we
would do a q a back and forth where we
roast each other we actually went on
comedy central and do like a rose battle
where we would roast each other but also
yeah i i saw that it was pretty funny
that was like
like uh god it was great you got no it
was great and you guys have great
chemistry you guys clearly are close
friends
um i it's awesome you found a partner in
comedy crime
it's wild just putting putting jokes
online and
fans who are in some kind of
entertainment with that i just met
sarah walking into the comedy store in
la just watching shows
and we talked and she and then we became
friends and then we became
friends to where we can kind of roast
each other non-stop and then now
we have like this brother sister thing
where we just roast each other the
entire time and
it's fans like it's the best part of the
comedy show because we're just riffing
and having fun and
i'm not looking at my notes and sweating
and trying to think of a punch line i'm
just we're just going to go with it and
it's
it's worked out really well it's awesome
we've had so much fun with it
again so impressive like you know that
the thing i love about it is that you
clearly have such like a perpetual
growth mindset because like very very
few people who are at the top of
uh the wrestling field getting like paid
a lot of money would be like you know
i'm gonna do this other thing that
is gonna be really difficult it's gonna
be really
difficult too yeah cool yeah and and
not exactly like throwing money at me in
the same way
um and the rest of it and the fact that
you would
line it up with your wrestling events
like
it just shows the love you know it's
really impressive to me
uh yeah i i love that and i and i want
to be good at it and i
don't i don't want to do the we know you
from wrestling hi
and they're already smiling when you
walk out i don't just tell some
wrestling story or something
because one day i mean people do that
and one day that could be a thing but i
go i'm actually trying to be a comic
so i'm working on material so i'll stick
in some stories so you guys stay in the
seats and come to the show
but i am actually trying a set up in a
punch line
and i've seen it no response and then
the sweat just starts pouring down your
face
anyway i was beating up john cena the
other day and then they wake back up
[Laughter]
so you've also branched out into uh
various
tv roles and and filmed you know just to
return to something really quickly
um uh one of the ideas out there was for
wrestlers to join the screen actors
guild
particularly now when it seems like the
vast majority of the activity is
actually like on tv because it used to
be you know you're doing like 80
of stuff not you know people aren't
seeing but now it's it really is very
much like you're all showing up for a tv
program
um but it seems like you have
aspirations in a number of different
directions
uh and you seem like a the kind of
person who's very very goal-oriented
like what is a goal that you're pushing
for either in wrestling or in comedy or
uh outside of those two uh it's it's a
little bit of everything i i pride
myself i
even when i just used to play sports and
want to be on saturday live as a kid
it's
it i am really goal oriented and every
day even to
like i'm gonna have pizza on thursday so
let's get a second workout in on
wednesday and if you don't get it done
you're not going to get the pizza like
i even do that every week so i i do have
the goals and i
this year until covet hit we were i was
going to double
the most amount of shows i had ever done
in a year we just announced a bunch of
different things
and i was in double those shows and i'm
not a fantastic comedian
but i'm okay and i'm learning and
getting the reps in
and i really wanted to double those
shows this year and
and uh i'm kind of half and half between
phoenix and la
and i was gonna start getting a couple
different working on some tv and movie
stuff
and uh right now most things are shut
down but the goals are
to use that i can be used for a funny
political
analyst in the back pocket technically a
comedian technically a tv show guy
i i did a movie a wwe studios movie
countdown
which was really bad but i was pretty
decent in it and and to have all these
and the wrestling and all these things
in my back pocket to where
just like when i was getting called up
that last time and didn't want to get
fired
to where i go here's every option i am a
modern day
renaissance man where would you like me
to
help you with this tv show this youtube
show
this comedy tour and to have everything
in my back pocket where
much like you know hoping wwe has no
option but to put me on tv
much like la has no option but to take
me for something or meet for a [ __ ]
meeting because of all the stuff that
you know
so it's just it is those goals every day
and hitting them
wow modern day renaissance man nick like
you you genuinely resemble that
it's it's cut it's kind of awesome
[Music]
here at yang speaks you know we think
that our data should be ours
and right now your internet service
provider can see every site you've ever
visited
even if you use incognito mode incognito
mode really does not work
as well as you think nor does clearing
your history
at this point you can have your data
sold and resold legally
to ad companies how do we improve on the
situation expressvpn
reroutes and encrypts your internet
connection through their servers so it's
like
you're beaming in from a whole nother
place and no one can
identify anything you did if that sounds
appealing to you
then sign up for expressvpn and go to
expressvpn.com
yang to get three months free on a one
year package
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
yang expressvpn.com yang it's the number
one rated vpn by cnet and wired
companies use it and if you are
interested in securing your data
this is the service for you
so you threw uh you threw political
commentator
in there and i appreciated the fact that
uh you know recently on social media you
started engaging politically you were
like look
this stuff's kind of important like i i
know some of you might not love
everything but let's like actually
talk things out and like you know be
reasonable human beings which you know i
completely agree with
yes but it's difficult to get like
even people who agree with you if you're
just like here's this point
and even people would agree like yeah
because those crybaby lives blew it it's
like no no listen man
like this one point is good and then
tomorrow
trump's to have a middle p middle east
peace deal that you kind of got to say
is okay
you can't just say it's bad you know
what i mean and it's so
like and uh even if someone agrees with
me with like just
rhetoric or a negative video get the
hell out of here let's all talk
go yell at everybody else go yell at
trump's twitter feed
if you're here we're all going to engage
in some talking and uh i took a little
break because it was really hard to have
a conversation
and i i have no hard feelings like i
have a heart of stone i don't give a
damn about anything what anyone says
about me if it's a good
if you sing me or make fun of me in a
good way like go lose some more matches
or something like you get me i get it
it's funny
uh but i want it to be good and
entertaining and i want it to be
i want both there should be more than
two signs but that's a whole other
conversation but i
wanted to be human beings engaging
and not just being so mad that they want
to go out in the streets or
wish death on somebody talking about
politics
i i certainly appreciated uh your
openness and the fact that you looked at
it and
and said uh hey guys like you know we
can agree on
uh some things disagree on others like
this is one thing that you have to say
and arguably like you know
like that was pretty good uh
and what you just said about a third
party
um i don't disagree that we need a
different
level of dynamism in our political
system uh that right now the duopoly is
not
great for anybody
i hate it oh well even as the numbers
guy
i think the last numbers i saw 30 of
americans
self-identified as democrats maybe 25
republicans and then 40 independents
and so you look up and say well that's
quite a quite a great deal of people
that
self-identify as independents and then
when it comes to this sort of election
everyone's like well you got these two
choices and you're like
like is it like how quite did this
happen uh
again um so to to me the path forward
um is to have rank choice voting so that
they're just different points of view
reflected
and you don't have anyone bullying
anyone saying like can't waste your vote
can't waste your vote
now like it in this circumstance i'm i
like it you know everyone knows i'm for
joe and kamala and i i think trump needs
to go
um but i also think that the the fact
that we have
um we have so many americans who are
just like oh like
you know i i feel like my vote doesn't
matter because by the time it gets to me
i'm like
choosing between uh people that i would
not have chosen um
is not good for democracy it's not good
for the country
yeah i completely agree and it's the
funniest thing it's like 2016. everyone
goes
i don't like either one of these two and
then they would
like i was i was doing some political
homework then they'd be like ah but i
might
try trump i don't know we'll see and
then now it's
i can't stand these two old rich white
guys
but they're gonna vote they're gonna
vote for them and march in the streets
to like announce their votes and i that
blows my mind because
everyone goes you could pick whoever you
want whatever like no we get told
there's two to pick from
and we get told how bad they are every
day and then go well
it's like that simpsons episode where
it's like uh
the two monsters space monsters come and
land and he goes we gotta pick from one
of us
one of us a republican one's democrat
and he goes i'm gonna vote third party
and he goes go ahead throw your vote
away and it's like and then the next
they're all enslaved in camps and it's
like it's the monsters rule the world
and it's
it's so heartbreaking because i know
that there's a lot of similarities on
both sides to where
that is that that middle ground that 40
of people who want something else
but tend to agree with 95 of everything
on the sides and
all day long we [ __ ] and find these
straw men of like this fringe right or
fringe left that we can go see
they're all just like that and you know
and it's it's
it's disheartening because i've been
around a little bit and i've seen things
happen and i kind of know that it's a
show and a game and you're getting
things done and you're going back and
forth but young kids today who are
online all the time
think that twitter is real and this is
how it goes and this is life
and one it's not accurate that's like
five percent of the world is on twitter
and everyone else is doing real life
things
and if you just go i'm so mad at ben
shapiro right now and you go outside and
you're like
he has nothing to do with you gardening
in your backyard and it's
which by the way i i love you on venture
piro show i uh
very few people will talk to him which
is sad
but you guys uh fantastic i love that
back and forth different points of view
and you talked
like gentlemen and made some great
points people should do that every
single day i think
you made so many excellent observations
in there it's almost like you're
you're a comedian
but social media turning us against each
other 100
uh that that's happening um people
like internalizing things and like
trying to mischaracterize
like you know an entire set of millions
of people based upon
like you know one obnoxious person like
that that definitely happens
uh but one of the things that i think
you bring to the table
um that has been true for other folks
who are
in either well generally comedy because
i hang out with a lot of comedians
um it's that if you go and travel around
the country
i forget name drop chappelle that's fine
let's just get it out of the way
oh if you go near ohio man um you know
back to your home stomping guns
so uh but like folks who have to
interact with
groups of americans in real life in
different parts of the country
uh in bars clubs wrestling arenas
autograph sessions it's like you have a
very different sense
of this country and of human beings
than uh just like turning on tv and
being like oh these people that people
because like you've actually met
thousands and thousands of people uh in
uh you know in in their everyday lives
and and then the caricatures don't
really stand up
i mean certainly i had that experience
running because like i met thousands and
thousands of people
like you yeah you i mean i'm somewhat
i've been around some people in bands
and stuff but you just like
two years ago like how does that you all
of a sudden
know five million people and you go oh
right people are for the most part
decent and want the same thing and want
to have a conversation
and how cool is it that people want to
shake your hand back when you're allowed
to shake hands
well you know i'm happy to say nick that
i kind of assumed that
most people were uh pretty reasonable
and just wanted the best things for
themselves and their families so it
wasn't like when i went out of the
country i discovered
it was more like i confirmed um what i
already knew
because i grew up in a town and like i
remember the kids i grew up with and
like
you know like did we do some dumb [ __ ]
that you know
like if you were to paint it now in like
social media like you know
like uh like would it look terrible sure
like are those people are are those
people
um somehow terrible human beings of
course not like you know we're just like
we're
like um you know [ __ ] teenage idiots
like
it was a different time we were lucky to
have that non-social media world and
non-camera world
and you have to do stupid stuff as a kid
and then the point is
you grow and then everybody wins
i and sometimes i feel that
people don't want you to grow they want
to make an example of something
uh and go oh you didn't atone for this
properly this thing you did 20 years ago
and you go ah it sucks
um but i did i'm talking to you right
now doesn't this count as me
growing up like nope
yeah okay again people are so much more
reasonable in person than online it's
like
like if you just stick two people in a
room it's like they would not say
ninety percent of like the nasty things
that they'll like put in a social media
post this is not the way
people are they they interact um
so nancy and trump in a back room are
laughing and cheering like she's got a
little
little glass of wine and he's got a
little diet coke and they're like anyway
we'll get back to yelling at each other
in public in a minute but let's take a
break
well i've certainly been on on media um
uh like shows where the commentator
will be very different to me as soon as
like the camera stops rolling and then
like when the camera comes on then you
know it's like we've got roles to play
and and as someone who was relatively
new to that i was like well this is
bizarre you forget
like you're on a tv show and that person
is maybe playing a character
so so he can get another 18 to 49
5 000 people to watch on their uh punch
in
on their nielsen ratings or something
but like and then as soon as it's off
it's like oh hey great points man that
was really cool
you couldn't say that on tv i was like
yeah i mean that that that's not an
inaccurate description of some of the
the things that i saw
[Music]
you've seen them they've made you think
about
whether or not you should get them and
those
are the earbuds that are sticking out of
everyone's ears and you're like do i
need to get them
and do i want to do the same thing
everyone else has done in terms of
getting
the particular earbuds that look that
way well we've got a choice for you
that is efficient exciting
innovative it's the raycon everyday e25
earbuds they're best ones yet with six
hours of play time
more bass i'm not really much of an
audiophile but the things
sound great they actually make your
music sound better
than really anything else i've used uh
and i barely noticed that [ __ ]
so if you're in the market for ear buds
and
you want something a bit different that
says something about you
you can get 15 off your order at buy dot
com slash yang that's
by recon dot com slash yang for a
special 15 percent discount on raycon
wireless earbuds
check it out now by raycon.com yang
they're black they're cool they're like
little obsidian
earbuds you stick in your ears and they
work great
and you can get them at half the price
of the other guys you know who i'm
talking about
there's a 45 day return policy so if you
don't like them you just return them
no questions asked but talk about
efficient i mean
half the price uh is is hard to argue
with
plus i hate to say it but you lose these
things
[Laughter]
and snoop dogg wears them snoop dogg
endorses two things corona
the beer not the virus which i love and
raycon earbuds
so you know they're legit
uh so so i want to think about like the
major
overlaps uh in terms of american history
between pro wrestling politics and
comedy so let's think about this
um you'd have to put at the top of the
list donald trump because he was
literally like a wwe character
a tv star massive entertainer yeah he's
a hall of famer like he invites her
[Music]
and you know he was clearly like a tv
star and then
he ran for president and and won um
so that's that's certainly the top of
the list of the overlaps um
i'd i'd say second on the list would be
jesse ventura
because he's like a high level wrestler
i grew up with you know him on t on tv
and then he becomes governor of
minnesota
uh and uh it you know is i think still
um campaigning for various things uh uh
so so that that would be second on my
list i'm thinking
about who who number three would be of
like the
nexus between politics wrestling and
comedy has a comedian run
and uh oh you also from minnesota i do
not know if this is
uh coincidence al franken i was gonna
say drinking he's a high school wrestler
too
um i did not know he was a high school
wrestler yes
i don't know i tend to so i i read a
bunch
which i don't know if that's popular
these days your numbers got you know
everything but
uh franken so i'm gonna i love saturn
live my whole life
i read that he was uh and he was getting
into politics and i was excited to read
his books and i remember he
i hope i get this right he wrestled in
high school was pretty decent
and also something along the lines i
think his brother was going to be
drafted
and he helped him cut weight like he
would for wrestling to get down below a
certain number
so he wouldn't be drafted into the war
which is amazing because he knew how to
do that from high school wrestling which
is
it's a wild story but also he was
someone who's really smart
and was doing political jokes on
saturday live when half the crowd didn't
get him or they did
and and uh of course him like taking
comedy and being known but also being a
smart guy and making it into a
somewhat i think jesse ventures was more
of a grassroots movement of
getting through uh with so many people
but when you when you want
positive things done and you have a
little bit of that star power you can
you can embrace into it and be that
character or go or have some fun with it
and then also
you're like yeah but uh this wetlands
needs to be protected
they're like okay yeah whatever you say
ventura and i checked it off like oh we
got it done
like i thought it was hard you know
oh um as someone who ran for president
uh i can attest to the fact
how wild is this is that that's amazing
oh you know you get used to it
eventually um though though it is still
kind of a joke like because you could
say it and it's funny
like it's you know it's always
always good for a laugh um yeah in a
positive way
but yeah oh yeah in a pot i mean you
know it's like
it's like i think everyone um
i think everyone loves like you know
different qualities about the run where
like part of it part of its appeal was
the implausibility i think
there was like that that sense of it um
no we showed them [ __ ] anyway
uh but as someone who ran for president
i can attest to the fact
that a lot of the time what's happening
is
there's a fundraising dinner
not not like a [ __ ] fundraising
dinner for yourself but those two
um or a group of activists gather
uh or a town hall
and then they're like and this person
now is going to tell you
what they think for an hour and take
questions
and they have to uh
they have to inspire but also entertain
and engage uh and command the room
uh and have a sense of uh
both theater and uplift and i did that
hundreds maybe even thousands of times
uh over
like the last couple of years so if you
think about that
skill set or that situation uh
both pro wrestlers and comedians are put
in those kinds of positions also
hundreds and hundreds of times where
it's like here's a group of people
here's a microphone or you know
or and actually for wrestlers too it's a
microphone because half the time you
just go out and you cut a promo
um and and so the parallels
among these three things to me are
actually very very very high
when you get into the nuts and bolts of
what the activities look like
and there's one story i'll tell
where jim clyburn
has all of the candidates down for uh
fish fry in south carolina
um and jim clyburn's like you know most
powerful guy in south carolina is
like one of the primary reasons why
joe's um
the nominee uh and so everyone's there
literally they're like and it is a time
when there are still 20 presidential
candidates in the field so it's me
joe bernie like warren beto like you
name it everyone's there
williamson uh marianne was there too
um i i love marianne uh mary and i are
dear friends
yeah she's great um and
because it's the clyburn fish fry we all
have purple t-shirts on that say clyburn
fish fry
and uh and like there's zero like uh
resistance from anyone it's like sure
give me the purple t-shirt so we're all
like
standing there um it's 80 something
degrees
uh and the instructions to you are
uh you're gonna go out to this crowd of
hundreds of people here in south
carolina at this fish fry
and you have 60 seconds uh because there
are 20 of you
and we cannot actually give you any
significant amount of time
so so so
that is the situation it's like you have
60 seconds to like
you know thrill these hundreds of people
go um
and i [ __ ] you not nick i essentially
cut a wrestling promo
yeah i think that this this video is
probably available online so if anyone's
uh
like anyway they can go find like the
video but it was like
like it was um you know i think i got
introduced as like the leader of the
yang gang and i went out and was like
what was like this and like i had enough
fans there where there
are people cheering and i got this thing
and then i walked back to the the
uh scrum where like every cat and like i
i kid you not i think
um like at least one candidate mouth
like
like
what the hell was that like what the
hell did i just see here so something
like that
like it was the whole thing was uh funny
um like my campaign manager was in the
pen so he said like that
like uh that that joe biden was like
that was really good
to like no one in particular where you
know they're around
so so i'm i'm telling this story just to
say that
i genuinely think that the skills of a
professional wrestler would lend
themselves very very well
or a comedian because a comedian's put
in a similar similar boat
and one of your former colleagues uh the
rock you know always gets talked about
in this context
as a presidential candidate and whatnot
uh
like so present company accepted because
i think you genuinely could do whatever
you wanted and if you decided to
run for like a high office in arizona
like you know i would not bet against
you you'd like uh you know
so um so
uh of the folks that you know like uh
your first just observation about like
the parallels and then
uh is there anyone you know in the field
where you think oh that person's gonna
end up
doing like you did either branch into
comedy or politics like from
from your you know like gajillions of
interactions with various folks
well yeah you see so like i mean of
course like we're lucky
guys like the rock come back sometimes
and
they're so gracious it's it's unreal
like no cameras around
anything like just genuine guy so
freaking great but also i'm not fighting
him for a spot for the intercontinental
title so i'm sure he might have had a
different attitude at one other time
but uh it is so great to have that and
see that and then know that the biggest
star in the world
came from the company i'm working at i
think that's freaking mind-blowing
uh but you see that i and for i know you
probably think i just kind of got into
talking politics a little bit ago but uh
i studied political science at kent and
i like the whole plan was to be a lawyer
and then go on saturday night live fight
in the ufc and then become
uh president of the united states but
now i kind of want to do it just so the
next time we have this podcast i can get
as someone who ran for president
and then i could set you up for a
question
but i i have the the people who
work really hard uh i tend to gravitate
toward them backstage
and two of my friends uh zack ryder
who's matt cardona
uh with aew sometimes now and uh the miz
and john morrison the four of us we
became friends
just because we were always trying to do
some other thing
10 years ago zack ryder was trying to
get a youtube show
going before we were even using youtube
for wwe let alone the billion
subscribers we have or whatever
just so he could use that and have a
chance at
getting something going on tv and he was
always going above and beyond and
we can say that like hey man i came in i
pitched i did all my things but
it's out of my hands now and he was
going above and beyond to film these
videos and then
someone like the miz who is constantly
pitching other places to go do a show to
be an appearance to go do anything and
always saying yes to get his foot in the
door something else
just to make himself more affable more
of a star
in wwe just to be more valuable and john
morrison same thing
he did movies tv's always doing
different ideas and it's those
people who want more constantly and like
you
you've been very kind to me like i'm i'm
i feel like i'm really good at wrestling
i got it
i i want to keep i want to apply that
to comedy and i'm going to need 15 years
to be good at it but i'm at year 4
or whatever and i it's just you want to
keep going and setting those goals and
we just gravitated toward each other
uh the miz and myself grew up like seven
minutes apart
i never saw i never saw him one time i
we're the same age
shane gray never saw him once in my life
but at wwe
we started gravitating toward each other
because of our love for the cleveland
browns and watching them lose every week
but also
it was for they won last night's big
deal uh but also
constantly moving forward and going hey
i bet if i did this thing
i could get my foot in the door here and
then wwe would have any
a one percent bigger star and i could
use this and and it just
and it's not in a bad way like jumping
off point to get the hell out of here
it's
to make the company better and that
mindset you don't have to have it but
having it makes all of us just want to
want to get better and want to make the
company better want to leave it better
when you leave
want to set a better example for
everybody else and say hey you can do so
many other things
and it's just it's exciting i i probably
all worked up i was like those guys are
my friends
because we all want to be awesome at
this and i think that's so cool
[Music]
there was a ted talk a little while ago
about how the content we consume is a
little bit like food
you know where you you can you know what
junk food is
for your brain the question is what what
is
good food well what is like the content
that actually will elevate you
that will make you feel like you have a
better sense of the world
the the new yorker to me is one of the
paragons of quality content providing
they really commit
to journalism that gives you a better
understanding of the world
i've been a fan of theirs for a long
time uh and
we all know their caption like the
cartoons and whatnot
uh that you know i got to participate in
a new yorker caption contest
and it felt like i was part of a
literary history a little bit
you know it was like an elevating
experience so the new yorker has a
special deal
for subscribers of yang speaks that
knocked my socks off
you can get 12 weeks of the new yorker
for just six dollars
that's a savings of 50 plus listeners to
my show
will receive an exclusive tote bag free
wow
a new yorker tote bag that'd be classy
go to new yorker.com
yang that's n-e-w-y-o-r
yang to get 12 weeks of the new yorker
for just six dollars in a free tote bag
new yorker.com yang i'll say this
on the trail the new yorker wrote really
great pieces about us i
always thought were fair one in
particular emily witt wrote a piece in
july of 2019
right as we were getting heating up and
he said how andrew yang's robot
apocalypse can heal a divided nation and
it was a fascinating piece
so again for a limited time you get 12
weeks in new yorker just six bucks
at savings of 50 plus listeners to yang
speaks get it the exclusive tote bag so
new yorker.com
yang that's n-e-w-y-o-r-k-e-r-dot-com
yang to get 12 weeks in new yorker for
just six bucks
and a free tote bag newyorker.com yang
[Music]
so i am thrilled that you
think you might want to engage in
politics uh at some point because
you'd be tremendous man i mean i kid you
not like you have
so much of what uh people would be
dying to see uh in
um someone who runs for office um and i
loved your original
set of ambitions it was a ufc uh
snl white house
english mr barker goes where do you see
yourself in 10 years i was 17.
you know ufc use it to get on a saturday
live
and then uh then become a politician a
wrestler then politician uh
but still that's pretty close i got a
couple of those in there
so i get the sense um from this
conversation that if you were to
describe yourself politically it would
be something
of an independent where you you see
things uh
um in a non-partisan way is that
accurate uh yeah it's very much so i go
out of my way to do that um i lean a
little bit right
i like lower taxes i lean a little bit
right um
i i've done some stuff with uh fox and
fox business and
even the people on the left who have
been on panels or with me like they're
fantastic they're so smart i love it
uh but i i lean a little bit right and
uh i
uh but every issue i don't just go down
the line and go this is it and put the
yard sign out i
i want to examine every issue and i feel
like what you mentioned earlier there's
that 40
of people who have this don't really
totally relate to a party but
we want this general idea and they're
not really spoken to as much
and i i feel like there's that huge
middle and i and i don't
i'm an independent because i hate every
the two candidates that's not the case i
just
i lean right and uh i want more people
to meet in the middle and i
am very pro third party let alone
freaking
20 parties just to give people some
different options you know
yeah i think the path to a third party
really is a different voting system like
ranked choice voting because
you know it like it's it's a case where
the mechanics actually make a world of
difference like
if if you give people the ability to
vote their preference
uh and there's no there's no pressure to
you know again like
avoid quote-unquote wasting your vote
and the rest of it um
and the reality is that both party
registrations are actually declining
over time
you know like neither republicans nor
democrats are uh
in growth positions uh in that way and
so
to me like if you're
uh if you're pro-democracy but also even
if you're pro these parties trying to
become more responsive to people
and maybe even resuming um like a growth
position
um then they need to try and engage with
different types of people and have
different types of ideas and that was
one of the reasons why i ran
is that i thought the democratic party
could use some new ideas
including universal basic income which
strikes me as not terribly
left or right like it's just inevitable
i was gonna bring it up relax i know i
know the deal
well thank you nick look at that
do you think uh unaoc in 2028 all this
stuff i have all these notes
no i i think that's that idea
shouldn't be i i i don't want to sound
this wrong like it shouldn't be a crazy
idea to go
we can't try this thing where you don't
trust the government and you're sick of
them ruining your money we can't
trust the people with it just one time
and see what the hell happens like
we we tried out trump like we wanted
an outsider why your idea should not be
a crazy idea
when we give we waste money in the
government so much
they mismanagement mismanage it a lot
and you go
let's give we you've met all these
people
you see that for the most part they're
good they want to do better
people some people are going to blow it
sure but that's life you know what i
mean give them a chance
because the government's going to blow
most of it anyway so let's get a shot
you know
yeah we just lived it too and people got
this 1200 stimulus check back in april
and i dare say it was awesome like
people people loved it
yeah yeah i know people people like did
what they did um
but uh but but but by the numbers like
you know it worked like there was a
study that came out afterwards and
it made me laugh nick it was like like
giving people twelve hundred dollars
reduced poverty and i was like
yeah it it really did
like great work so
so yeah like i think uh i mean right now
um something like 75 percent of
americans are pro cash relief during the
pandemic including majority of
republicans and democrats
everyone's like look this is common
sense i and yeah everyone's on board
with us
it just seems like the election's in
coming up so we all have to fight about
if you can get 150
or 450 but nobody wants to lose points
politically which
this is that part of the game where it's
like guys
people are going to vote for trump or
biden how it's going to go
give these people a couple hundred
dollars for having to sit at home and
shut down their business
like come on yeah i completely agree
no one's in the room well there's the
people that are the the best
uh toward the like correct approach are
like the
independent members of congress right
now who are like look we're tired of you
guys not being able to come to a deal
like here's like a compromise deal
i think it got um maybe 40 or 50 members
of congress to back this thing
and if you look at that what that is
nick it's like a bunch of people
expressing
dissatisfaction with nancy pelosi and
house leadership just taking the stance
and then not
uh not moving they're like look like
let's just freaking get something done
for
the people so that that to me is where
the vast majority of americans would be
yeah you can't like it's it's i don't
think
and if you're playing this as a game
with people who were forced to close
their business down
that's already bad enough but it's like
we can't let them have a couple hundred
dollars because trump won't look like a
dick
like okay like give people the money
uh i i would try to find out who was
waiting for the debates or debate or see
whatever
most people are said in their ways i
understand that but i feel like
and this is a question i feel like
how do you think this debate's gonna go
what is it you know it's in a week or
something right
in cleveland september september 29th i
was in cleveland look at that i didn't
even know that i'm gonna become
in there but i don't think i can i think
i'm gonna get in
mean i don't even know what their live
crowd looks like uh yeah september 29th
is the first debate
and it you know i actually told a joke
nick uh
to someone i was like imagine how you
think this debate's gonna go
it's gonna go like that
well because it's true it's like we know
who these people are like you know he's
trump's going to be here joe's going to
hear that are they going to do their
thing and
um you know and very few minds will be
changed uh
you know i think i saw something that
said seven percent of americans are
undecided and i have a hunch that even
though seven percent actually know how
they're going to vote
yeah i should really say yeah i feel
like people know i
as much as i don't know what i'm gonna
do because
i study all day i do the homework i
wanna watch these debates anything that
happens i watch and observe
i know i know the two people already
period
and it's just i go i i wanna see is
trump gonna say
a bunch of untruths the entire time
probably but also it's politics
everybody kind of lies the whole time
for the most part but then also
is biden going to be sharp
i don't know i don't think so but does
that
change who you're voting for for
president because he
couldn't as quickly lie as the other guy
i don't know
i you know i it's the performances are
pretty baked in
uh having been on the debate stage with
joe a number of times like
you know and had and and had and had a
bunch of
uh just informal conversations with him
in various environments
um he's still uh
very sharp and like you know doesn't
show any
signs of uh fatigue even after like
hours on stage and whatnot like
so i think that you know i think that
these performances aren't going to
change a whole heck of a lot personally
sadly it won't it doesn't matter and
people are already voting by the way i
think so
i mean some people that's true too yeah
so
some early ballots are out pretty pretty
soon it's true yeah
i mean i'm not watching it to roast and
zing i'm like
can you be a little bit more normal
trump just for the day
and like brian can you just be
zing him back one time or something just
so we we know the deal but
i know it's baked in everybody knows the
deal people know who they're voting for
uh
but someone like me who does all this
homework is like the hell am i supposed
to do here
i would have voted for you well thank
you brother i appreciate that
i appreciate that well so though the
homework we have in my opinion
nick uh is trying to enable greater
diversity of viewpoints
and it is to push for like a change in
mechanics so if you have something like
rank choice voting which really should
be
non-partisan because you're just like
look let's just let people express their
preferences
a lot of people on the left are for it
ben shapiro just said
uh he's for it like pretty much like no
one
except for folks who just love the
status quo
and who the hell loves the status quo
really like you know like if you're
saying you don't love the status quo
so so it's so if if we see and above who
do all the voting
i think it's them they're like we don't
want change i'm old and i don't want
anyone messing up they might they might
not be four right choice voting it's
true but but
the rest of us if if we get behind rank
choice voting
uh then you'd see a different
approach to politics very very quickly
i'll give you one example from it nick
where if you have ranked choice voting
in there like let's say four candidates
in a race it reduces the incentives to
negatively
uh campaign because if you trash someone
else then
you both look bad and then the person at
third place ends up beating you both
so that's so that would be such a
massive
welcome shift um you know that because
uh
that to me is where we have to try and
lead people if you're gonna try and
educate folks is that
right now like you know we can all get
mad at each other all the time but like
the anger is not gonna actually solve
our problems or move us forward it's
like what can we do that's gonna help
clean things up
um and one thing that's true of me i
think the miz is is this too
and this is one thing i'd love to ask
you about a little bit it's like i'm a
dad and so like you
look at your kids and you're like what
the heck we gonna leave for them uh are
you like the most eligible bachelor on
earth is that like the the story
i wanted to hear you say it but no i no
i
uh i don't i kind of like i i tried
i tried it dating around but i kind of
like doing my own thing even now
when i have a lot of down time uh i'm
like
one night i'd like it'd be nice to have
someone to go watch a movie with and
then i go yeah the other six nights i'd
really like to watch
family guy on my own here without having
to like bother somebody
i don't know uh but i i'll i'll take
your kind words
yeah technically accounts is uh eligible
my girlfriends are getting mad at that
but still
no i mean uh certainly um
well one thing like i you know i think
that would be really
interesting from you which i think you
probably thought about um
is i feel like you have a book in you my
friend i feel like there should be like
the nickname
story and i i i can't imagine i'm like
the first time
or the first person who said that sort
of thing to you uh that's true
uh yeah it's it i think you're very
correct
and um i got about about an uh eight or
ten month window
right now and a lot of down time to
figure out
and i think i'm going i just actually
had a few talks with a few people i
think i'm gonna get
starting on that pretty soon and i'll
probably get my brother involved to help
me out because
he published self-published a couple
different books and got a few things out
there so
uh i we have this down time i have some
pretty wild stories
and uh must your stories must be out of
control
so i i totally think you should write a
book during this time
or if not right because one thing that
happened one of like the best sports
books not to say it was a sports book
that kind of would be i mean it's a lot
of things like you've got a lot to offer
um but like i think it was like the
andre agassi book
where he sat down and just told this
dude like his stories
and then like that that person uh helped
craft
like some of the things um so if it's
your brother it'd be great but i
i [ __ ] you not man if you just sat down
and like just
told like told so many stories and just
hit the recorder uh like i i literally
think you'd have half the book written
in like a week uh just because like
because i because i know it's daunting
to sit down and actually like
you know write pages and pages uh and so
i'm just
i'm just putting in like this like uh
apparently the way
andre agassi's book take took place was
like he just told a bunch of
like he told this person the stories and
they put it all down and then like the
book like
took off from there so that's just me
giving you like uh you know
like yeah i i think i'll do some i i
wanted to do something like that so yeah
because i don't want to type that out no
way
but tell sit there tell some stories
i've been putting notes in my phone
my friend justin roberts was like just
put notes down on your phone when some
story you remember something
put all these down i could tell to
somebody and actually a long time ago i
read a
pam anderson did a book a long time ago
and she just she took her life and
changed some names and made it a parody
and kind of changed a couple it's like
instead of nikki sixx it was like ricky
rick's or something like
things around he was like jimmy lee
instead of tommy lee or something like
and changed a few situations and added
in some crazy stories and then that way
i can tell the crazy stories of the last
15 years behind the scenes
and what's happening but also people can
still go home to their families but i
can make it very exciting so i feel like
that wow you could
you could do that you could do like the
thinly veiled fictionalized version
wow that might even be better i don't
know man like either would either would
be a home run
because like yeah because your your
stories would just be freaking epic and
of interest to millions
um
so is it so aside from writing this book
which you should totally do
uh what else are you working on that
that you want folks to know about
outside of the fact that they can see
you every week on uh wwe
of course you can see midweek uh but so
i i hate
i hate free time i'm so mad that i
wasn't doing more in this off time
so i i kept i i forced myself to get
you know uh i have a book that i read
just on plane rides and i have a book
that i read in my backyard
getting reading done but most
importantly um i have stacks and stacks
of notebooks that i've been filling up
for comedy shows for years
and i go and now i'm out of practice i'm
just getting into a little bit of a
rhythm and now i'm out of it so i've
been writing down everything whether
it's in my phone or in these notes
and walking around my backyard and just
trying to stay
unrusty so the second we are good to go
and have some shows back one i i need to
get to that uh
motley crew poison tour which got
cancelled this year which is really
about me i was going to like for the
shows i'm really bummed out
but uh more importantly when we get
those
the go-ahead to start opening some
comedy clubs are opening but it's
it's a little weird nifty right now when
it's good to go i'm gonna be ready to go
go out there maybe to an hour have the
shows and uh i've been working on the
material
and writing and writing and uh now some
of it's gonna go toward a book but
i'm ready to go to get back out there on
the tour and uh
i i can't wait to get out of my house
more so
well if if there was a world champion of
comedy
they should definitely have their eye
out for you because if history is any
indication you're going to end up
challenging for it
over a period of time nick thank you for
doing this
congratulations on everything man you
are uh you're
like an epic freaking uh against all odd
success story in many many respects like
like i have so much admiration for what
you and your fellow performers do but
you in particular
i feel like uh rose to the top through a
lot of stuff that you know frankly was
not in your favor
uh and the fact that now you're you're
just continuing to push yourself into
new directions and new fields i mean
you're you're such
uh such a dynamo such a powerhouse
there's like no limit to what you could
do i certainly would not want to be
your future political opponent um so you
and i have to
make sure and uh be part of the the same
general camp
well we'll figure something out we'll be
the the new age reformed
independent party we'll find somewhere a
cool
thing put it down there that we're in
yeah the country needs it brother the
country needs it
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to
yangspeaks and click on notifications so
we can let you know
every time we have a new episode
you